george this one's directed to you why
don't you explain to the people who are
unacquainted what the hitchhiker effect
is
we don't exactly know and i think a
hitchhiker effect should probably be
plural not just a singular form of the
term because there are many effects
the bass team first noticed it in a
correlation of things that happened to
people who visited skinwalker ranch in
particular there were at least five
maybe six
intelligence officials who during the
awsap program uh overseen and funded by
the defense intelligence agency these
intelligence officials visited
skinwalker ranch
had an encounter with something unusual
and then took something home with it we
don't know exactly how it works we don't
know why it happens but it's happened
over and over again it not only happened
to those people during the awsap bass
period but it happened to people who had
visited the ranch uh during the nids era
and and even before then where people
would go to this property encounter
unusual phenomena ufos whatever and then
they would go home and they were visited
at their home by orbs by craft by crypto
type beings poltergeist type activity
broke out in their homes in one
particular instance that we describe in
the book there were these very seasoned
intelligence officials
who as part of the bass asap program
went to the ranch to check it out for
themselves they're walking during the in
the middle homestead
at night it's cold and suddenly gets
much colder they hit a cold spot where
it goes the temperature drops
dramatically in a matter of seconds and
they were sort of on high alert in fact
these guys were on high alert the whole
time they were on the ranch because
they'd read and heard about it and uh
they encountered some sort of a an
intelligence that had a sort of a
menacing presence it sort of froze them
in their tracks they backed off and
later when they went home they had an
eruption of paranormal activity in their
homes it is and generally the way it
works is it spreads to their family
members uh the family members wives
children see these things ahead of time
the one uh character in our book axelrod
not his real name
we had to change that at the direction
of the pentagon when we submitted the
manuscript he had this explosion of
activity in his home that was seen by
his wife she saw this
standing on two legs a wolf creature a a
wolf standing in her yard
its paws
crossed like this
leaning on a tree staring back at her a
couple of days later she didn't tell
anybody about it a couple days later her
kids see it they scream this thing runs
off down the street they can see it's
it's running on two legs
it's kicking up leaves
uh and they didn't know what the hell to
think about it but there were other
things that happened in the home beings
uh shadowy figures seen in the home
things moving around on their own their
pet had been moved they found their dog
up on the roof one day all kinds of
trickster type activity and then it
spread from the kids to their friends in
the neighborhood
uh that has happened a bunch of times it
happened there was a female agent who we
did detail in the book
a very seasoned battle-hardened
professional
who encountered something with column
and he can tell you about it they
encountered some kind of a creature a
crypto creature that people have dubbed
the dino beaver again in the middle
homestead this woman when she goes back
home
it's an immediate explosion of what you
call poltergeist type activity not
saying it is poltergeist is just similar
to that kind of activity that's been
reported over the decades by poltergeist
researchers
in her home
a wine bottle flies across the room one
from one side of the room smashes on the
wall on the other side there are beings
that she sees at the side of her bed
things moving around in her home it was
so dramatic that her roommate who was
her fiance moved out ended that
relationship this activity has continued
for years um colin will tell you it's
happened to pretty much all of us who've
spent a lot of time on the ranch
including me i've never seen anything on
skinwalker ranch but my wife has
experienced things at my home column's
wife has experienced things in their
home bob bigelow's wife experienced
things in their home some of it is
benign and interesting and some of it is
downright scary we don't know why it
happens
but column with this biology background
can explain better about sort of the
effect of how it spreads it's like a
virus you mentioned it's benign and
sometimes deleterious is any of it
positive
not that i know of uh maybe column has
heard about that i mean it's positive in
the sense so wow i got to see something
really strange there
it's kind of kind of thrilling my wife
the first time something happened at our
home and i i tried to make this happen
for a long time before i knew about the
hitchhiker effect i would bring things
home from skinwalker ranch to my house
try to engage whatever it was bits of
rocks and scrap and things taken from
the homesteads little tiny bits and
pieces to try to get it going and
finally it happened and it wasn't
pleasant my wife saw these blue orbs uh
floating over our uh our house at night
she called me to come up and see him by
time i got there they were gone and then
there was an experience in our bedroom
where this uh this thing came in
i'm not going to go into a lot of detail
on that but it was a very frightening
experience for her unpleasant and she
didn't want it to happen again well um
you know the interesting thing about the
uh hitchhiker effect is that it is
very very reproducible you know george
george said that you know back in the
even in the 90s the knits people
were experiencing this effect
but in terms of reproducibility
um
we know that uh going into between the
zero which ended really in 2003 and the
bass era the asap era which happened
really beginning in 2008 2009
multiple security officers were deployed
on the uh on the skidmarker range
property
a lot of those people we've personally
interviewed about a dozen of them and a
lot of those people have brought quote
unquote brought something home same kind
of thing um poltergeist activity in the
house sometimes they see orbs in the
house
um and then getting into the asap era
where everything seemed to really
escalate and uh these
these uh five out of five 100 of the
military intelligence people who were
deployed at the request of the defense
intelligence agency onto skinwalker
ranch did as george said bring something
home with them um and you know even
after robert bigelow sold uh skinwalker
ranch
we have a new era of brandon fugle the
uh proper property developer from utah
purchased the ranch he installed a team
on the property and lo and behold we
have another set of instances of the
hitchhiker effect um and remember the
people who went on skinwalker ranch in
2016 were very very skeptical and they
were saying this is all you know this is
not absolutely you know this is all
fantasy and then stuff started erupting
in their homes they brought something
home with them and multiple instances so
in terms of reproducibility
the hitchhiker effect has continuously
affected people uh for that we know of
for about 25 years
um it may be longer on skin marker ranch
and the second point i wanted to make
was that it is not only skinwalker ranch
it is not sort of
only happening on skinwalker ranch but a
lot of a ufo um activity
does seem to give rise to the skin
walker or the uh the hitchhiker effect
for people who have never been on
skinwalker ranch and just interact with
the the ufo phenomenon they uh
themselves in some cases i'm not saying
in all cases but in some cases and
mostly where we have the
luxury of being able to study these
people over many months or many years
a lot of these people
you know
report
elements of the hitchhiker effect you
know it's kind of ironic but going all
the way back to 1947 kenneth arnold uh
when he saw those nine
objects in the sky over the cascade
mountains
uh on june june of 1947
it's interesting long after he died um
his daughter went on a radio show she
was uh talking about writing a book
about his life but she started talking
about seeing orbs in the in the arnold
home
so
experience various poltergeist effects
uh even kenneth arnold himself in his
book um talks about uh you know some
really weird happenings that were
happening um after the uh june 24 1947.
i'm not unambiguously tying what
happened to kenneth arnold to some form
of the hitchhiker effect but i'm saying
that this effect is not just a
skinwalker ranch specific effect it
happens on a much broader scale